[Music]
the struggle to eradicate polio is the
subject of Time magazine reporter
Jeffrey cloggers new book splendid
solution this talk hosted by the
University of Baltimore law school in
Maryland is half an hour
well good evening everybody I'm Bob
Bogomolny president of the University of
Baltimore and it's my pleasure to
welcome all of you on behalf of the
University of Baltimore community to
this evening's event our speaker and
guests is Jeff Kluger who's a 1979
graduate of the University of Baltimore
School of Law and I always feel that one
of the best ways to measure and get a
sense about a university is by looking
at its graduates and we are happy to
have him as an example of a person who
studied here and I must say from my own
standpoint one of the great pleasures of
my activity is being able to spend time
getting to know our graduates and the
wonderful things that they've done as
you'll hear mr. cloggers career is
extended beyond the conventional path of
the law and that really reaffirms the
belief that I have that a law school
education can lead to so many things it
provides you opportunities for a wide
range of activities and the emphasis on
critical thinking the use of language
reasoning is one of the hallmarks of all
that and every once in a while it even
can sort of prepare you to be a
university president so you never know
how these things turn out on a personal
note many of you know I had a career in
the pharmaceutical industry and in
ancient days well before you even
started law school I actually edit a
book on human experimentation so the
field of drug development and the whole
idea of dealing with critical illness
through science has been a great
interest of mine for many many years and
I look forward today to these
discussions at this point I'd like to
ask Dean Holmes to come down to
introduce our speaker
good evening everyone thank you for
coming out I'm Gilbert Holmes I'm the
Dean of the University of Baltimore
School of Law and I'm absolutely
delighted to have you here today
our law school takes great pride in our
alumni and Jeff Kluger is no exception I
met Jeff last fall during an alumni
visit to New York City and when he
described this project that he was
working on
I said well Jeff you've got to come to
the University and let us host your
unveiling of your book in your hometown
Jeff is a native of Pikesville and so
this is his hometown coming out and in
fact his mother splash is here and I
know that regardless of how old you get
mom always likes to come to your
recitals
so welcome splash to this event Jeff is
a 79 graduate of the law school he's a
senior writer for Time magazine and has
been in that position since 1998 he was
a contributor at time for two years
before that one of one of his writings
or his writings have included a book
that he wrote with Jim Lovell called the
lost moon and that book served as the
basis for the Ron Howard movie Apollo 13
and so he had lots of opportunities to
understand science and the like and in
fact has taught science journalism at
New York University our law school for
20 since 1925 has been empowering legal
systems Jeff Kluger proves to us that we
actually empower more than legal systems
and you're in for a great time
Jeff spent some time with students today
at lunch talking to them about
alternative careers and I got an
opportunity to sit in on part of that
and found out that he's a very warm
engaging humorous individual who's a
great storyteller so sit back relax and
be ready for a great time and story from
our alum and author
Jeff Kluger thank you very much
you know it's puts me in mind of the the
first time I was anywhere near a stage
at the University of Baltimore was in
the fall of 1976 when I was an incoming
law student and was attending the
orientation session for four new
students and we were in the auditorium
over at the law school for a session
being conducted by a professor brilliant
and fearsome professor royal gee Shannon
house property professor I don't know
how many people remember him and I
remember being in the audience knowing
that he was going to call on a poor
unfortunate bring that person up to the
stage and grill him mercilessly on a
case we had all read he did call a name
which blessedly was not my own guy came
up to the stage and was in his own
anxiety positively smother in the
microphone you could have heard his
voice on Pratt Street it was right on
top of it and professor Shannon house
said in his singular voice don't eat the
microphone just stand in a reasonable
propinquity thereto
and I thought I am over my head already
I am just I'm completely out of my depth
so it's nice to be back and be a little
calmer than I was 28 years ago I wanted
to I'm gonna read a couple of short
passages from from this book but um but
I did want to talk a little bit about
what drew me to the story of Jonas Salk
and the polio vaccine and it was it was
more than being a child of the
mid-century I was born in 1954 just the
year they started testing the polio
vaccines so like every other child born
then and earlier I was living at the
mercy of my immune system and the the
lottery of the the luck of the the viral
draw I dodged that bullet as as as the
large majority of kids did but the
stakes for being in the small minority
were so huge in the suffering so
profound that even though most most boys
and girls escaped it it was hard to
escape the shadow of it one of the
a lot of wood drew me too - the story of
Jonas Salk was similar to what drew me
to the story of Apollo 13 for me a lot
of pneumatic roads run to and from that
story in both cases there was a very
very clear narrative arc the story of
Apollo 13 played out over just six days
in the confines of a spacecraft two
spacecraft actually the story of the
polio vaccine plays out literally over
millennia but the truly intense have
truly focused work on the project
particularly from sulks point of view
covered just three years from 1952 to
1955 and took place almost exclusively
on the first three floors of municipal
hospital at the University of Pittsburgh
in both cases there was also a ticking
clock in the case of Apollo 13 that
ticking clock was the exhaustion of the
consumables consumables being air water
and power when they were exhausted so
with the lives of the astronauts be in
the case of Apollo of of the Salk story
it was more of a kalindra chol clock it
was a clock that began taking every
April as soon as the weather grew warm
and the hot pocket of the Bayou down by
the Gulf states you would see the first
outbreaks of spotty cases of
poliomyelitis the infection would spread
through the Gulf region up to the
landlocked states of the deep south and
often just ride the Mississippi straight
up north spreading up into into the
Valley States and then off to the coasts
if you were a parent in New York and
Baltimore Sun Chicago somewhere to the
north you would see this viral storm
front you would see this viral storm
front gathering and know that you were
hopeless in the face of it you would
know that there was nothing you can do
if you lived in in if you're afraid of
earthquakes you either don't move to
California or you tell yourself probably
quite realistically that that the big
one won't strike in your time in the
case of polio it would always happen it
would happen every summer and it was a
case of pure arbitrariness as to whether
you or your child was going to be struck
also in both cases there was a
charismatic prototype
just in the case of Apollo 13 it was Jim
Lovell in the case of the polio story of
course it's Jonas Salk and what struck
me about both stories as well finally
was that the books could open with a
cautionary tale about what happens when
everything goes wrong in the case of
Apollo 13 it was the Apollo 1 fire that
claimed the lives of three astronauts on
the launch pad
astronauts Grissom white and Chaffey in
1967 in the case of the Salk story it
was the polio epidemic of the summer of
1916 Jonas Salk was born at a very
auspicious time in history he was born
in 1914 in 1916 in New York City the
worst polio epidemic to date in the
history of the country struck in that
city and he was in the target
demographic he was in the sweet spot of
what the disease looked for two years
old and presumably with a vulnerable
immune system two years after that was
the great flu pandemic that killed 50
million people worldwide by the time
Jonas Salk was 41 years old he had
developed our code developed a vaccine
against both of those diseases but the
book nonetheless opens with the summer
of 1916 and I'm gonna read two very
short passages there was little that
parents or the city could do to protect
against the flu except beginning with
quarantine at sort of at the retail
level when influenza or when when polio
appeared in the house the house was
quarantined with it if it spread from
that house to the block the block was
quarantined and in often as not the city
would send black cars there only a
hundred and sixteen thousand cars
registered in in New York City at the
time and most of the ones that were
owned by the city that were shall act
over on the door with an emblem of the
city of New York we're seen as one of
the city's newest and modern
acquisitions and they became symbols
however of terror because the cars were
dispatched into the neighborhoods to
make spot checks on the polio houses and
houses that weren't complying with the
quarantine room rules would typically
lose their children the child would be
taken away to swine in burn island off
the coast of Manhattan
where child leader would either recover
or often does not not recover and this
first passage was is tells a bit about
that story mothers did not surrender
their sick babies easily often kicking
and cursing the city physicians as soon
as they arrived things typically went a
bit smoother if a social worker came
along since the mothers seemed more
inclined to turn a child over to a woman
than to a man the absence of a social
worker usually meant that the doctor did
not intend to take the sick child away
though lately that had become an
unreliable sign since as the epidemic
progressed the city's overworked health
department simply had fewer of the
ladies to spare alone or unaccompanied
the doctor would walk quickly up the
steps to the house casting a fast glance
at the knot of mothers who stood
avoiding his eyes the first thing the
doctor would do when he entered a
paralysis home was look around the
parlour to determine whether the father
had taken to sleeping there if he had
that would count in the family's favor
the rules of the plague required that at
the initial signs of illness the child
and the mother retreat to the family
bedrooms and stay there until the
infectious phase of the disease had
passed the father who would have to
continue working and otherwise moving
through the community was to isolate
himself as well as he could this meant
that he was not to go up the stairs
beyond carrying up food and other
essentials and the mother and child were
not to come down until there was no risk
of either of them carrying the contagion
further if a cot and clothes and the
parlour convinced the doctor that the
father was complying with the
regulations he would next go up to the
bedrooms to examine the patient the
scene that greeted him there would
almost always be a bleak one by June was
proving to be a punishing summer with
temperatures typically rising high into
the 80s before noon and staying fixed
there until well after sundown the
bedrooms of poliomyelitis patients would
often be stifling since the windows
would be closed against the blue flies
stable flies and house flies that were
widely suspected of carrying the virus
the Health Department permitted
quarantine families to open their
windows if they had metal screens in
place but screens were expensive and not
always available in the room the child
would first get for the doctor would
first asked the mother to describe how
the child's illness that's
rook though he knew what the answer
would be the same akes the same chills
the same sudden loss of strength then he
turned to the patient feeling the
child's head and neck to determine if
there was any fever he moved the legs
and arms to see if there was any pain
he'd bend the legs at the knees and
asked the child to push back to
determine if there was any lingering
strength in the muscles then he laid the
limbs back down if he concluded that the
disease was still burning inside the
child and that the parents had been
sloppy about the quarantine rules
he'd interpose himself between the
mother and the bed and gathered their
child up prepared to fight the curses
and kicks of the woman as he did
carrying the child downstairs he'd hoped
the father would restrain the mother to
say nothing of himself so that he could
take the patient to the car with a
minimum of unpleasantness if necessary
he would summon his driver whom he'd
have left behind the wheel for
assistance if that didn't work he'd
summon the police if on the other hand
the doctor found that the fever had
passed and that the house was well
sealed against leakage of the virus he'd
leave the home in peace the disease
after all would by now be through with
the child having entered and left
cutting a hot path through the spinal
cord along the way the wasted legs might
never be of any use again but the child
would no longer be a danger to anyone
else if the doctor did announce that the
child could stay the mother would cover
her face with her hands in relief when
the doctor clumped back down the stairs
with no child in his arms the grateful
father would often is not offer up an
impulsive gift the cigar man would
insist that the doctor take a cigar the
boot man would offer him laces the Baker
would offer him a ring of cake they
pressed the unwanted tributes on the
doctor and he would mostly take them
once in his car he'd pass them on to his
driver this went on throughout much of
the summer with children being taken
first to swine burn Island and then when
that was filled to other other
facilities in outside of Manhattan and
outside of Brooklyn in the other
boroughs down to Staten Island sometimes
which at the time was called Richmond
which I found rather charming and later
toward the end of the summer taken all
the way out to Woodmere in Long Island
we're a hospital was built to care for
for crippled children and to to research
the disease that hospital was also
filled before before September came one
of the great ironies of polio was that
it was paradoxically a disease of good
sanitation polio has been with us for
thousands of years or had been with us
for thousands of years one of the the
earliest indications of it was an
Egyptian carving of a young man with a
withered right leg that looked for all
the world like a leg that had been
stricken by polio carrying a walking
stick there is virtually no other
disease known that causes precisely that
kind of kind of atrophy but pulley only
appeared very spottily very sporadically
until indoor plumbing and and
comparatively modern sanitation were
developed prior to that children were
routinely exposed to low background
levels of polio and throughout the early
years of their lives that would pick up
tiny subclinical cases of it that would
lead to a bit of a cold a bit of a flu a
bit of a fever something that looked a
little like polio but maybe wasn't quite
and then would pass as quickly as a cold
well a few of these that in fact were
polio and you develop a good robust
immunity against the disease once you
establish indoor plumbing though you
take away that low background exposure
then you get into your second year third
year fifth year six year of life you
have an immune system that's naked to
the virus and when a truly lethal strain
of the virus comes along you're knocked
flat it's no coincidence that the first
place there was ever an epidemic was
Stockholm in 1887 when there were 44
children children struck by polio about
15 years later a thousand kids in were
struck by polio and in Stockholm and by
1916 in the u.s. 25,000 people were hit
the second short section I want to read
deals with what what the city of New
York and other cities by implication in
the summer of 1916 33 states were
affected but what the city of New York
in this case did when quarantine rules
house-to-house quarantine rules failed
and how the city itself tried to
tried to clamp down on the spread of the
virus the fourth of July was a
predictably festive day in New York and
this year was no exception with more
than 500 patriotic meetings to be held
around the boroughs electric signs had
been erected at City Hall and in Times
Square Columbus Circle and City College
Stadium spelling out patriotic messages
from the mayor the governor and
President Wilson himself in incandescent
bulbs that would blaze with the
brightness of 55 million candles a great
deal of work had gone into planning such
a day and a great deal of it would now
have to be undone on the afternoon of
July 2nd the health commissioner Haven
Emerson known mostly for being the
gentle great nephew of author and poet
Ralph Waldo Emerson called his
assistance into his office in the
Municipal Building on Center Street in
Manhattan it was a hot and gummy day
with our thermometer climbing to 84
degrees and not showing any sign of
falling at the Polo Grounds on the
northwestern edge of Manhattan barely
15,000 people showed up to watch the
Giants fall to the despised Brooklyn
Dodgers
most of them leaving early to escape the
afternoon Sun as often happened when the
temperature rose the paralysis bug
thrived and throughout the day hospitals
around the city were knocked back on
their heels as seventy-two stricken
children were rushed in for care by
their parents more than 20 of those
patients already seemed certain to die
Emerson reviewed the numbers from both
the hospitals and the Weathermen and
issued a series of orders of the 60
biggest celebrations plan for the night
of the 4th 15 would be canceled plans
for city city sponsored open-air movies
would also be scrapped children under 16
years of age would be banned from all
places where large crowds gathered
including movie houses and theaters
exhibitors or other businesses caught
disobeying the new regulations would be
stripped of their operator's licenses
more than half a million leaflets would
immediately be printed and distributed
explaining once again how to follow the
paralysis hygiene guidelines Emerson's
rolls went promptly into effect and the
polio bug slapped them aside as the week
pressed on and the temperature stay at
high 113 new cases checked into
hospitals on July 5th and 87 followed on
July 6th for every 5 cases at least one
proved lethal within the first two days
as the muscles that control the
children's breath
along with the ones that controlled
their arms and legs when the weekend
arrived the numbers fell and parents
were briefly hopeful but it was a false
hope a result merely of spotty reporting
as the case counters in the hospitals
took their Saturdays and Sundays off
when Monday arrived in the 3-day told
was tallied the counts soared again in
the neighborhoods terrorized New Yorkers
began freelancing solutions cats many
people concluded were responsible for
spreading the bug and so cats were
bludgeoned and drowned by the tens of
thousands when word got out that there
was a bounty on the animals heads boys
in Brooklyn rounded them up and brought
them hissing and scratching to the Board
of Health when that word turned out to
be a mere rumor the boys killed the cats
themselves in houses where polio had
already struck the animals were murdered
with special fury flung by rage blind
parents into the rivers sometimes when
the cats were already dead sometimes
when they were still alive
more than 70,000 cats were killed that
week but even after they were gone the
epidemic roared on if cats weren't
responsible the people concluded perhaps
mosquitoes were if it wasn't mosquitoes
it was rats or sewers are the always
dirty Gowanus Canal New Yorkers called
cabled and wrote the Department of
Health with all manner of other things
they were certain was causing the
paralysis plague including high ground
water ice cream cones excavations flies
bed bugs street dust corn flakes the
subway parasites and the water alloys
and cooking utensils gases from you
nisshin's factories the bent-over
position children assumed at school
desks mercury poisoning white clothing
earthquakes volcanoes electrical
disturbances sunburn intestinal
derangements second-hand bedding decayed
food excessive glare unclean milk
bottles carrying coins in the mouth and
tobacco with so many possible sources of
infection more and more people decided
to quit the city altogether in train
terminals in all the boroughs mothers
and children who had the means began
fleeing in numbers that judging by
railroad ticket sales exceeded 50,000
the actual count was probably far higher
since children under five traveled for
free meaning that there was no complete
tally of just how fast the city was
hemorrhaging its young for all this the
paralysis count still climbed in the
first full week of July
five hundred and fifty two children fell
ill in the second week the tally
approached one thousand at the peak of
the epidemic the worst year of an
epidemic of the polio epidemic in the
u.s. was 1952 when nearly 58,000
children were sickened or killed which
is significantly more than the the toll
of all of the deaths in Vietnam and that
was in in just one summer one of the
things that I'm say one or two more
quick things and I'd love to open it up
for questions one of the things that
struck me the most about Jonas Salk was
his single mindedness and the clarity
with which he saw things the the anyone
who's done research before and we were
talking about this a little bit today
knows that collections of documents
personal collections of paper are kept
in file boxes about this big and as a
way I imagine of terrifying the people
who want access to those boxes the
finding aids are listed not so much in a
number of boxes but in linear feet of
shelf space consumed by the by the
collection the Salk collection was over
750 linear feet of shelf space which was
about six hundred and eighty four boxes
papers files documents letters memos lab
notes in all of those I came away with
one impression
first of all Jonas Salk did not doodle
anywhere I was astounded I looked at
page after page after page of lab notes
nothing the only thing close I found -
it was on what looked to be a scratch
pad and he must have been on the phone
and I saw a triangle with two lines in
it and I thought this is it the entire
body of Jonas Salk's artwork there's
going to be a retrospective at the
Whitney next week I think but it took
that kind of ferocious single-mindedness
to do what he did he had to and we can
perhaps get into this in a moment but in
order to develop a polio vaccine he had
to flip on its head how a vaccine was
developed and how a vaccine was made
effective and how you didn't make a
vaccine he came up against scientific
orthodoxy he came up against medical
wisdom he came up against science itself
it was politics there was money there
were an enormous number of things
involved and when I looked at these
boxes and
that what he did I realized this was an
act of scientific pointillism this was
an act of of mosaic work a tiny
brushstroke at a time when I would get
into the middle of a folder of a lab
notebook that was just page after page
of incomprehensible glyphs to me and the
only sense I could make of it was what
was written at the top was that it was a
single test of a single formulation for
toxicity of an oil fortification in a
vaccine in the kidneys of lab mice mice
3 through 28 and there were 1,500 mice
tested I realized that the level of
detail and level of foresight you have
to say to say I can immerse myself in
the kidney of this Mouse and fill a
notebook with it because I know
somewhere down the line this is one tiny
tile in this vast mosaic of work I'm
trying to put together to conquer polio
and to do it coming up against
scientific orthodoxy just before I went
to a reading last night in New York at
Barnes & Noble my older daughter ELISA
who's 4 years old said something that
really strikes struck me and every
parent thinks their children are
precious and pre she and mine are but
everybody thinks that but she was
sitting in my room as I was getting
ready to go and I just reached over and
turned my alarm clock toward me and she
said why did you turn the clock and I
said well to see what time it is and she
said to me and to see what time it's not
I said well yeah sure I mean that goes
without saying by implication there are
many more times it's not than times
there or it is but that I think is what
Salk and people like him were able to do
you look at the clock and you also see
what time it's not he was able to turn
things on their head to say here we are
and I'm gonna stand outside and see what
else there is to learn by not looking at
what's obvious that's what struck me
about him and that's what brought me to
this story
and I'd love to take any questions at
all anyone anyone might have yes
they were like Betty and Veronica if
anyone read Archie comics they did not
get along and they didn't get along for
two reasons first of all they didn't get
get along temperamentally
Sabin was a very acerbic man an
exceedingly cutty man cutting man
incredibly articulate if you got if you
didn't agree with Albert Sabin if you
didn't understand something he was
saying he'd approach you less with with
confusion that with a sort of disdainful
pity and this came across and his
dealings with people he was very lusty
about conflict about about engaging in
the cut and thrust of of scientific
debate Salk was exceedingly conflict
averse he didn't like confronting people
about things it's a hard thing when what
you've done is when you've when you
decide you're gonna be an unorthodox
scientist but he didn't like confronting
people about things so he would sort of
sidestep things today we'd call it
passive-aggressive back then we just
called it you know cautious and
diplomatic so they clashed at that level
they clashed at the temperamental level
they also clash most inform or
importantly at the level of scientific
ideology saw bullets the the received
wisdom before Salk started working on
this was that there's one way to make a
vaccine against a virus based disease
you weaken the virus and then you inject
it into a person into a body a weakened
virus cannot cause a disease but it's
enough to wake up the immune system it
recognizes the disease and it develops a
standing army of antibodies so anytime a
wild virus comes along they're ready for
it
problem with weakened viruses is they
can mutate back and there were often
cases of vaccine associated disease
either in the person who had received it
or in people around that person because
when the vaccine when the virus passes
through the body it often mutates in a
single passage through the body from
safety to virulence Salk thought that's
madness to do that with polio if you're
talking about the common cold if you're
talking even about influenza you can
survive all of those things with with
with few consequences polio he wasn't
willing to try it on he said I'm gonna
kill a virus
I'm gonna do it that way and I'm gonna
prove that you can make a vaccine that's
as effective or perhaps more effective
than a attenuated virus vaccine with a
killed virus science said it couldn't be
done that getting the immune system to
hunt a dead virus was a little bit like
getting a fox to hunt a dead hound
it'll sniff around at it but it's
definitely not gonna launch a vigorous
attack so the two of them battled on
that and they were friendly and very
oftentimes not friendly rivals straight
up through through the rest of their
lives actually because both vaccines
were ultimately developed yes what was
the transition between the influenza and
the the polio vaccine what what caused
him to shift it was mostly it wasn't so
much a change in interest he had
developed him and his mentor Tommy
Francis had developed the influenza
vaccine and it wasn't so much a change
of interest or or a desire to go you
know I've got one disease to my name now
I'm gonna go bag another as much as it
was that he simply wanted to go out on
his own he he told dr. Francis that
that's what he wanted to do he said to
him his mentor said you're ready for
that you can do it but make sure you get
a good billet somewhere he tried a
number of glamorous assignments at some
West Coast universities East Coast
universities he felt there was some
element of anti-semitism involved there
may well have been at that point it was
it was fairly open and and fairly
flagrant he was ultimately invited out
to to the University of Pittsburgh which
was considered just an unspeakable place
to work it was a man he knew a guy named
Walter Schlessinger had worked there
quit the university in disgust he he was
head of the then University of
Pittsburgh virus lab which was
essentially a largely empty room in an
abandoned morgue in the basement of the
building when you've abandoned a morgue
when a morgue won't even live there you
got real estate problems the morgue left
this was salt slab it was essentially
unfunded it was essentially empty
pittsburgh at the time was of
course the smokey City when men would
have to take two shirts to work one to
wear in the morning and one to change
into a midday because the shirt would
have turned black or at least gray by
midday they had the Pirates who never
won there just wasn't anything to
recommend Pittsburgh he Saul came back
and and said I'm gonna take this job and
his mentor said oh you've got to be
kidding what's there and Salk said the
words that I voted many many times he
said I know at the moment it's just
empty rooms and promises but I just fell
in love with the place once he got there
he still wasn't sure what he was gonna
do it was either gonna be polio but even
then he wasn't thinking of a vaccine he
was just thinking of some tests and some
other basic study in polio it's either
gonna be that cold vaccine or measles
vaccine and shortly after he arrived he
was approached by sort of the the the
minor league talent scout of the
National Foundation of infantile
paralysis who was a man named Harry
Weaver who was known for collecting
great talent and the NFIP which is the
organization was founded by Roosevelt
after he contracted polio and later
became the March of Dimes it was they
were looking to they were beginning a
program to type the virus to make sure
they that there were only three types of
polio virus because before you could
even consider a vaccine you got to know
how many types of virus you have it does
nobody any good if you say there are
three types of polio virus and we've got
killed sample of each of those three
viruses in this shot and then you find
that there are types four or five and
six out there so they had to make sure
that only three types existed it was
grueling just rote work you would give
it to a grad student and say call me in
two years if you're still alive it's
just it's a horrible tedious job Salk
took it on and three other labs took it
on and once he was done with that he had
sort of earned his first polio stripes
and he said this what I'm gonna do I'm
gonna develop a vaccine
it was around 1947 1948
I want to thank everybody very much and
Geoffrey Kluger is a senior writer at
Time magazine and co-author of lost moon
the perilous voyage of Apollo 13 which
was the basis for the movie Apollo 13
splendid solution Jonas Salk and the
conquest of polio is published by GP
Putnam's sons an imprint of a penguin
group visit penguin dot-com for more
information
[Music]